ابتسامه تعكس ارتياح القاده الاوروبيين
بعد قمه استثنائيه لمناقشه الدعم المالي
لاوكرانيا في خضم حربها ضد روسيا اظن ان
هذه المساعدات المقدره ب 50 مليار يورو
على مدى اربع سنوات هي رساله قويه لبوتين
قبل ايام من الذكرى الثانيه لبدء غزوه
الهمجي الرئيس الاوكراني ثمن التوافق
الاوروبي بشان المساعده
لبلا انها رساله واضحه اوكرانيا ستقاوم
واوروبا سوف تقاوم من المهم ان يتم اتخاذ
هذا القرار بالاجماع
لكن تحقيق الاجماع لم يكن بالامر الهين
معارضه رئيس الوزراء المجري وضعت الدعم
المالي الاوروبي لكيف على
المحك الاموال المجاريه لن تذهب الى
اوكرانيا لدينا اليه مراقبه في نهايه
العامين الاول والثاني موقفنا بشان الحرب
في اوكرانيا لم يتغير نحن بحاجه الى وقف
اطلاق النار فيما يؤكد رئيس الوزراء
المجار ان بلاده لن تدفع اموالا لاوكرانيا
حتى بعد هذا الاتفاق يشدد ماكرون امام
الصحفيين على ضروره احترام قواعد الاتحاد
الاوروبي المجر لم تحصل على هديه قدمنا
لها ضمانات بوضع اليه على مرحلتين بشان
مساهماتها الماليه ليس اجراء تمييزيا الق
واضحه منذ عام
2020 تعول كياف بشكل كبير على الدعم
الاوروبي والامريكي خاصه عند هذه المرحله
من الحرب حيث يواجه الجيش الاوكراني
صعوبات كبيره في وقف الهجمات الروسيه التي
تضاعفت خلال الاسابيع
الاخيره